poor old Donald Trump he tries to stop
what he calls America's endless wars but
in case you missed it he has started a
giant game of geopolitical whack-a-mole
instead so the US president pulls
American troops out of northeastern
Syria saying he wants to bring them home
from endless wars sounds alright ah he's
just abandoned is Isis fighting Kurdish
allies and they're facing an onslaught
from Turkey quick send a tweet saying
that you haven't abandoned the Kurds and
threatened Turkey that should do it
oh dear turkeys your ally too and it
just invaded Kurdish held territory
despite its strongly worded tweet ah and
now your allies realize that they could
be abandoned at any time and the Kurds
have to stop guarding all those Isis
prisoners they captured in order to
fight Turkey instead it's a nightmare
for the orange one but at least some
troops are coming home that should
please domestic friends and enemies Oh
No now Hillary's tweeting nastiness at
you actually no one cares about that now
Republicans are turning on you too even
the normally reliable Gulf Trump Senator
Lindsey Graham he's called you shameless
for abandoning the Kurds and trying to
stop wars I think they like the wars
deeming him from the left ear Graham's
Democratic congresswoman a OC who tells
Trump that he needs to pursue a strategy
to stop our endless wars without
endangering innocent lives
unfortunately I hear that stocks are
fairy dust are low at the moment you
know what just stick with the endless
wars it's just
[Music]